the conspiracy to kill Julius Caesar
began with a meeting between three men
Casius Longinus Marcus Brutus and
Decimus Brutus
[Music]
Casius was an experienced soldier in
general a decade earlier he had fought
the Parthian Thunder crashes after
crashes humiliating defeat Casius
rallied the survivors and successfully
defended Syria against the Parthian
counter-attack he would go on to command
a Pompeian fleet during the Civil War
and to everyone's surprise he proved
himself to be Rome's most successful
naval commander in a generation not that
it made much of a difference because as
we know Pompey was eventually defeated
and Kassius was captured but Caesar
recognized Talent when he saw it he
issued Casius a full and complete pardon
and put him in charge of one of his
legions destined for Egypt the
Alexandrian campaign turned out to be
kind of a disaster but thanks in part to
Cassius's leadership the Romans were
able to hold their own until
reinforcements arrived after Egypt
Casius let Caesar know that he would not
participate in the slaughter of Pompey
ants and so Caesar sent him back to Rome
Casius paid a professional price for his
loyalty because when it came to the
upcoming Parthian campaign Caesar
planned to stick Casius in a thankless
administrative job in Syria
[Music]
we've talked about Marcus Brutus before
there's not that much to say of his
early political career beyond the fact
that he aligned himself with the
ultra-conservative Cato
unlike Casius Brutus was not a military
man during the Civil War he joined up
with the Pompeians as far as we can tell
he didn't really do anything after
Pompey x'd effete he immediately
surrendered to Caesar who in turn gave
him the fairly important job of
governing Cisalpine Gaul promising to
fast-track him all the way up to consul
in the years to come you see through all
of this Brutus maintained a fairly good
personal relationship with Caesar
Brutus's mother Servilia had been in a
romantic relationship with Caesar for
about 20 years this was not seen as
unusual Servilia was an older woman
twice widowed plenty of children she was
free to see whoever she wished because
of this relationship Brutus had known
Caesar for his entire adult life if not
longer Caesar was happy to help out his
mistress's son however he could
[Music]
Decimus Brutus distant cousin had a
different story to tell Decimus was an
honest-to-god dyed-in-the-wool cesarean
he had spent at least five years serving
under Caesar in Gaul he even fought
alongside Caesar and Antony at the
Battle of Alesia you might even say that
he was in Caesars inner circle during
the Civil War
Decimus stayed behind in Cisalpine Gaul
where he impressed everybody by putting
down a pretty bad uprising after this
Decimus got the nod from Caesar and was
elected preacher next year he would be
heading off to Cisalpine Gaul once more
this time as its formal governor
each of these three men Cassius Brutus
and Decimus came to believe that Caesar
intended to destroy Roman politics by
crowning himself King in fact this was
already happening before their eyes
Caesar wielded most of the powers of a
king already and Roman politics were
becoming more and more irrelevant by the
day in their eyes the only way out of
this mess was to remove Caesar from the
equation he had to die
[Music]
but in order to get a shot at this first
their little conspiracy had to expand
and it didn't take very long to get some
top-tier politicians on board
people like Gaius turbo Gnaeus a former
consul general and veteran of the Gallic
Wars who had recently become
disillusioned with Caesar over his
treatment of the Senate
people like Tilia Cimber a preacher and
former caesarian who saw this conspiracy
as his ticket to power people like
Publius Servilius Casca a childhood
friend of Caesars now a Tribune of the
plebs who had since become so alarmed at
Caesars authoritarianism that he signed
on to this conspiracy to end his life in
the end 60 senators joined the
conspiracy which you could argue is too
many people roughly 7% of the entire
Senate way too many to keep a secret
[Music]
the 60 conspirators began to meet
regularly to strategize their next moves
the majority argued that the logical
next step was to bring Marc Antony on
board
he was Caesars consular colleague for
that year if he signed off on the
assassination perhaps that would pacify
Caesar's legions plus the conspirators
believed that they had a lot to offer
Antony after Caesar was gone if Antony
could bridge the divide between Caesars
veterans and the conspirators he would
become one of the most powerful senators
in Rome a consensus was forming but
before any definitive action could be
planned
the former consoled turbo Gnaeus spoke
up he knew Antony well as they had both
served under Caesar in Gaul he revealed
to the group that just last year he had
personally approached Antony as part of
another conspiracy and that Antony had
flatly turned him down
when turbo Gnaeus revealed this
rejection to the old conspiracy people
got spooked and the whole thing fell
apart why risk tipping their hand
trebonius argued when they already knew
Antony's answer the conspirators were
convinced fine
no Antony but what about Cicero he was
one of the few remaining former consuls
who predated caesar's rise to power he
was the guy who put down the Catalan
rebellion 20 years earlier a hero an
elder statesman maybe he was the one to
lead them out of this mess after some
debate the conspirators ultimately
decided against inviting Cicero into the
conspiracy we don't 100% know why but
one reason may be that in an effort to
influence the new regime Cicero had been
spending an unhealthy amount of time
with cesareans some conspirators may
have feared that he had gone over to the
other side another unusual aspect of
this conspiracy which may be pertinent
here is that it reflected a strong
generational divide for whatever reason
the conspiracy consisted almost entirely
of men
in their early 40s maybe these people
just knew each other the best or maybe
they had the most to gain in a power
vacuum who knows Cicero was well into
his 60s and quite simply nobody in the
conspiracy knew him that well
so Cicero had been fraternizing with the
caesareans and nobody in the conspiracy
could vouch for him
fine Cicero was out the conspiracy would
have to move ahead in its current form
one decision that the conspirators came
to pretty early on was that the
assassination should occur in public
this had to be seen by the people as a
legitimate act full of idealism and
conviction no back-alley murders but
beyond this vague statement of principle
there was very little agreement as to
how they should actually proceed
some people threw around the idea of
assassinating Caesar while he was
overseeing that year's elections in a
situation like that Caesar would be up
on a raised platform in full view of the
electorate that certainly met the
criteria of being public but how exactly
were they supposed to pull this off
Caesar would be up in an exclusive VIP
area surrounded by supporters and even
if they could pull it off an
assassination before the entire
electorate had a 100% chance of causing
a riot the conspirators might not
survive others considered killing him on
the way to the elections if they could
predict his route ahead of time they
could set up an ambush as he was
crossing a bridge Caesar would have
bodyguards there would be a tussle but
some of the conspirators believed that
if they moved quickly they might be able
to rush Caesar and push him off the side
of the bridge this probably wouldn't
kill him but they could have assassins
waiting below to finish the job
this was a better plan
but it was extremely complicated and a
big part of it relied on the physical
prowess of a bunch of nerdy ass senators
they've enjoyed with yet another plan as
a side business
Decimus
and to run a company of gladiators the
conspirators discussed using these
gladiators to somehow attack Caesar at
some public games you know leave the
killing to the professionals so they had
three plans on the table the election
plan the bridge plan and the gladiator
plan the conspirators went back and
forth for a meeting after meeting after
meeting debating pros and cons each
scenario introduced a dangerous amount
of uncertainty into the equation and the
group struggled to come up with any sort
of consensus this is one of the
downsides of having 60 people in the
conspiracy when's the last time 60
people agreed upon anything but then out
of nowhere
Caesar publicly announced what up until
now had been a closely held secret he
would be leaving Rome on March 18th the
conspirators had been operating under
the assumption that they would have
months to figure out a plan they were
wrong they had weeks this changed
everything all of the old plans were
thrown away and the conspirators started
again from scratch they still agreed
that the assassination needed to happen
in a public place but after debating the
old plans they now knew that it also
needed to happen in a controlled
environment preferably away from
bodyguards and potential rioters on top
of all that this new time constraint
meant that they had to throw the whole
thing together quickly it couldn't be
too elaborate
you know Senate meetings happened all
the time
a Senate meeting wouldn't require any
additional prep work it also had the
virtue of still technically being a
public place while at the same time
being nice and isolated Caesars
bodyguards would not be allowed inside
and then there was the whole symbolic
thing removing a tyrant during a Senate
meeting this was perfect finally the
conspirators agreed on something now all
they had to do was figure out the
particulars Caesar would be leaving on
March 18th so they agreed that their
attack should take place during the last
Senate meeting before his departure that
would be on
March 15th the Ides of March but
coordinating this wasn't as simple as
you might think
Caesar was personally financing a
complete redesign of Rome's downtown
area which included Rome's old Senate
house because of this the Senate had
been randomly meeting in various temples
scattered throughout the city the
conspirators agreed that the safest
thing to do would be to stash some
weapons on location but because of all
this bouncing around they couldn't be
100% certain where this particular
Senate meeting would be taking place so
instead they decided that a select group
of senators needed to hide daggers in
their togas this would be dangerous as
it was a death-penalty offense to carry
a dagger inside the boom area but it had
to be done for everybody else they
decided to smuggle weapons into the
Senate meeting using these baskets that
were always full of notetaking materials
if the location of the meeting was
changed at the last minute these baskets
would hopefully come with them late in
this process Casius brought up something
that had been troubling him what about
Antony Caesar and Antony were
co-counsels for that year and if this
thing was going down during a Senate
meeting Antony would be only a few paces
away knowing him he'd probably put up a
fight
plus if they were successful Antony
would be Rome's only remaining consul
what if he was angry what if he came
after them wouldn't it be much safer to
just kill them both
Casius then went one step further so
long as they're having this conversation
what about Lepidus he wasn't a consul or
anything but he was sitting on typer
island just outside of Rome samarium
with a full Legion if Antony declared a
state of emergency or something
he might ask Lepidus to cross the pó
maryam and restore order this would be a
disaster
Cassie's continued if on the other hand
they took out Caesar they took out
Antony they took out Lepidus they took
control of that Legion they would
probably be able to pressure the Senate
into endorsing yes
nation's retro actively Brutus strongly
disagreed they were not revolutionaries
they were not here to overthrow the
government
in fact that's exactly what they were
trying to prevent what they had all
agreed to do was remove a tyrant
what Cassius was talking about was a
purge this argument escalated and
eventually it split the conspirators
along partisan lines the former Pompey
ins sided with Cassius and the former
caesareans sided with Brutus after some
high drama
Brutus finally turned the tide he told
the group that like it or not caesar's
reforms were popular if they started
down the road of purging caesareans
they would inevitably end up repealing
caesarian legislation as well they
wouldn't be able to help themselves when
that happened
Brutus said the Roman people would turn
on them it would forever politicize the
assassination a better path he argued
was to surgically remove the rot at the
heart of Roman politics once Caesar was
gone everything else got easier this
argument convinced Cassius and the ex
pawn pans fine no purges Caesar only
[Music]
so what was Caesar doing while all of
this was going on just going about his
business making preparations for the
upcoming campaign but it wasn't totally
oblivious to the fact that something
strange was going on around this time
the priest spurinna
who in my opinion probably had contacts
inside the conspiracy began to warn
Caesar to beware the Ides of March
Caesar was getting other clues as well
although in the moment he didn't quite
know what to make them for instance days
before the Ides he pulled Casius aside
for a quick meeting when Casias left
Caesar turned to one of his aides and
said something like what's his problem
he looks sick on the day before the Ides
of March
Lepidus invited Caesar and Decimus to
his home for dinner and drinks as one of
the original three conspirators Decimus
had been careful to stay on good terms
with the cesareans and apparently this
strategy was paying off because even at
this late stage he was still in caesar's
inner circle the three men ate and drank
and chatted late into the night much of
the conversation centered around the
upcoming - Ian and Parthian Wars Caesar
and Lepidus would be leaving in a few
days and Decimus would be leaving later
in the year to go and take over as the
governor of Sicily in Gaul this province
would be key to keeping Caesar supplied
in Dacia and so the three men spoke of
stockpiles and supply lines and oh boy
it must have been riveting as the night
wore on and the drinking took its toll
the conversation turned philosophical
somehow somebody brought up this
question what's the best way to die
Lepidus and Decimus went back and forth
pontificating and Caesar got
uncharacteristically quiet
after a bit he made up his mind and told
the others that the best way to die
would be suddenly and unexpected when I
imagined this incident I imagined a
half-drunk Decimus dying inside and
trying to think of a way to change the
subject but it was fine
eventually the evening wound down and
everybody went home
the next morning Caesar
awoke to the sound of screaming it was
still hours before dawn and his wife
Calpurnia was inconsolable she told him
that she had just experienced the most
vivid dream of her life where she
witnessed the roof on their home
collapse in the last moments of the
dream the part where she was quite
literally screaming she saw herself
covered in blood and holding Caesars
mangled corpse in her arms after this
both husband and wife found it
impossible to go back to sleep
so they got up and spent hours talking
as they waited for dawn the ancient
sources take care to point out that
Calpurnia was basically an atheist and
that she wasn't the kind of person who
believed in prophetic dreams by now
Calpurnia had definitely herds Barinas
warnings to beware the Ides of March
today was the Ides Calpurnia's
subconcious appeared to be playing out a
version of the thing that she feared the
most when the Sun came up
Caesar complained to his wife that he
was feeling sluggish and dizzy some
historians have taken this to mean that
Caesar
may have had a seizure in his sleep but
with the drinking the night before how
could you possibly say that morning
Caesar was scheduled to make an
appearance at some minor religious
ceremony in his capacity as Rome's chief
priests this thing would have taken
place literally steps from Caesars front
door not a big time commitment Caesar
went to the ceremony and spot its Farina
across the crowd
Caesar playfully called out to him The
Ides of March have come spur ena
responded mysteriously yes The Ides have
come but they have not yet gone
when Caesar returned home he complained
to Calpurnia that he still wasn't
feeling well the two talked it over for
a bit and they eventually decided that
since Caesar would be leaving on
campaign in a few days he should rest
and recover while possible the Senate
was scheduled to meet that day so Caesar
sent word to Antony to go ahead and
cancel the meeting on account of him
being sick Caesar had just unknowingly
up ended the conspiracy
[Music]
like a flash Decimus showed up at
caesar's home and asked him why he was
canceling the meeting caesar told him
about Calpurnia's dream and about how
neither one of them had really gotten
any sleep
Decimus laughed in caesar's face calling
the whole thing superstitious nonsense
he then played up the misogyny angle and
said that if it got out that he was
canceling Senate meetings on account of
his wife's bad dreams a lot of senators
would take it as a deliberate insult
after a pause Decimus was like I'm not
supposed to tell you this and then
revealed that certain senators had been
working behind the scenes on a bill that
would allow Caesar to use the title of
King so long as he was outside Italy
Decimus continued saying that the bill
was not universally supported and so if
Caesar insulted the Senate now it might
never see the light of day this was a
bold-faced lie the bill did not exist
Decimus made it all up but the lie
flattered
Caesars ego and so it was super
effective he agreed to go to the Senate
meeting Decimus his quick-thinking had
just saved the conspiracy
on their way a guy named Artem odorous
pushed through the crowd grabbed Caesar
and put a scroll in his hand he told him
Caesar read this quickly and read it
alone it concerns you personally Caesar
was constantly getting approached on the
street like this and so he handed the
scroll off to one of his attendants and
continued on his way later
investigations would reveal that this
scroll contained detailed information
about the conspiracy Caesar would never
read it now I mentioned before that the
Senate couldn't meet at their normal
Senate house and that for the time being
they were ping-ponging around the city
to a bunch of temporary locations as
dumb luck would have it today's Senate
meeting would be happening in a place
called the Theatre of Pompey outside of
Rome samarium the theatre of Pompey was
actually an entire complex of buildings
that had been financed and built by
Pompey at the height of his power
it included a theater in arena a temple
a place for shopping all sorts of
amenities super fancy early in the day
the Senate meeting would be taking place
in the temple and later in the day there
would be some kind of gladiator thing in
the arena next door wait a second
gladiators Decimus had gladiators
apparently when Decimus learned the
location of the center meeting he tried
to get his gladiators signed up for the
games next door for whatever reason they
were rejected so instead their plan was
to just loiter outside the arena as if
they belong there with their weapons in
broad daylight not exactly subtle
in case anybody asked they had an
elaborate cover story prepared about how
they were waiting to see if another
gladiator showed up so that they could
arrest him for violating a contract
anyways
Caesar and Decimus were extremely late
to the Senate meeting so most of the
Senators were just hanging around
outside the temple making small talk
but not Casius he was all alone inside
the temple looking up at a
larger-than-life statue of Pompey in
complete silence
after Poppy's death Casius had been one
of the few who proved his loyalty by
refusing to take up arms against his
fellow Pompeians what was he thinking
here
commotion outside indicated that Caesar
was approaching so Casius snapped out of
it and went outside to greet him looking
around Casius would have been able to
see a lot of his fellow conspirators in
the crowd
kasia's hadn't seen Decimus for several
hours so he pulled up beside him and
Casca another conspirator just to make
sure everything was all right
a mob of senators each wanted a private
word with caesar so they would have to
wait a while before they could head
inside as Casius and Decimus and Casca
were waiting some Rando senator named
leanness approached them and said way
too loudly
Casca Brutus told me your little secret
how dare you keep me in the dark like
this
Casca panicked the dude continued I hear
you're running for a diol when did this
happen
as leanness was making a scene
another Rando senator somebody from
outside the conspiracy cold Casius and
Decimus aside in hushed tones he told
them I hope that you accomplished your
task please do not delay people know and
they are talking Casius and Decimus were
stunned by this they looked towards
Caesar but everything appeared normal at
that moment that loudmouth leanness made
his way over to Caesar pulled him aside
and made a big show of whispering
something in his ear cassia sent Decimus
and Casca watched with their hearts and
their throats maybe they should just do
it now maybe Decimus should get his
gladiators but it was nothing leanness
walked away and everybody started making
their way inside on cue the conspirator
turbo Gnaeus pulled mark antony aside
for a private word
Caesar entered the temple and took a
seat in his special golden chair slash
throne as this was a Senate meeting his
bodyguards remained outside under normal
circumstances Antony would be sitting
only a few paces away but for the moment
he was still outside with turbo Gnaeus
this particular Senate meeting was
pretty poorly attended of the 900 or so
potential attendees only 2 to 300
actually showed up of this 2 to 360 were
in the conspiracy
that's what 20 to 30 percent massive
it's no wonder that people were talking
a signal was given and a bunch of
conspirators rose to their feet and
moved towards Caesar Tillis Cimber
loudly asked Caesar to consider
pardoning his brother an ex pon pan who
had fled after the Civil War as Cimber
made his appeal the rest of the
conspirators slowly fanned out and
formed a perimeter still seated Caesar
answer'd zimberg saying that his brother
had shown no contrition or remorse
whatsoever and so no he wouldn't be
pardoning him anytime soon by the time
Caesar was done speaking
Casca was standing directly behind him
suddenly Cimber reached out and grabbed
Caesars toga yanking it hard exposing
his bare shoulder this was the
predetermined signal to attack
Casca immediately drew his dagger and
stabbed down as hard as he could he
missed the dagger grazed Caesars
shoulder and drew a bit of blood Caesar
grappled with Casca shouting Casca what
are you doing another version has Caesar
shouting this is violence a quick
reminder that Caesar and Casca had known
each other since childhood conspirator
and non conspirator alike were frozen in
chalk Caesar and Casca were engaged in a
little tug of war but nobody moved to
help either one of them for several long
moments nothing happened
finally called out in Greek brother
helped me Casca's brother tie tedious
sprang forward which broke the spell
suddenly the room was a flurry of
activity Caesar was able to rise to his
feet and get free of Casca the first
person he saw was Casius who drew his
blade and slashed Caesar in the face
Caesar backed away right into Casca's
brother tie tedious who stabbed him
between the ribs two non conspirators
rushed forward to help Caesar but the
conspirators forming the perimeter held
them back the rest of the conspirators
pushed in attacking wildly Decimus
delivered a nasty wound to caesar's
thigh Casius then struck for a second
time but amid all the pushing and
shoving his dagger was deflected and he
ended up hitting brutus with friendly
fire stabbing him in the hand
eventually caesar's leg wound got the
better of him and he fell to the ground
Brutus came forward hand still dripping
with blood and hunched down over the
dictator
Caesar spoken Greek you to my child
Brutus stabbed Caesar between the legs
those were of Caesars last words he
pulled his toga up over his face
to preserve his last shred of dignity
and he died coincidentally Caesars body
had come to rest directly underneath the
statue of Pompey
[Music]
now that the deed was done
many of the conspirators suddenly found
their courage and took turns stabbing
Caesars corpse they would be part of the
assassination if only symbolically even
with this bit of post-mortem stabbing
Caesar only sustained a total of 23
wounds that means that the vast majority
of the conspirators just stood around
and watched the assassination in fact
using the ancient sources we can
confidently track five of Caesars wounds
number one from Casca to the shoulder
number two from Casius to the face
number three from Casca's brother tie
tedious between the ribs number four
from Decimus to the thigh and number
five from Brutus to the groin it's very
possible that these five people were the
only ones who struck Caesar while he was
still alive the remaining 18 stabbings
may all have been post mortem earlier I
said that the conspiracy was arguably
too large but maybe I was wrong when the
big moment came as many as 90% of the
conspirators did nothing later
examination of Caesars body revealed
that of his 23 wounds 22 were
superficial and only one was fatal the
fatal wound was stabbing number three
the shot between the ribs delivered by
cast his brother tie tedious
[Music]
the assassination was over in like a
minute
many senators never even got a chance to
leave their seats silence filled the
room Marcus Brutus his hands covered in
blood
both Caesars and his own was the first
to move he approached the seated
senators pointed to one senator in
particular and shouted congratulations
Cicero you've regained your Liberty
[Music]